lecker sind anders und du merkst du
solltest zuhause
wahrscheinlichkeit bräuchte sie
vergessen
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute heute morgen müde
ich aufgestanden und habe mir gedacht
das richtig bock auf per mini und ich
habe alle zutaten wir brauchen auch gar
nicht so viele und das ist auch gar
nicht so aufwendig es dauert nur
manchmal ein bisschen um das ganze zu
formen aber auch das könnt ihr in
gruppenarbeit zum beispiel machen ich
habe jetzt hier meine mail schreibt euch
alle ganz genauen mengenangaben unten in
die
neben dem video beschreibung es gibt da
jetzt schon zum mail direkt mein salz
dazu damit sich das vorab direkt gut
miteinander verbinden kann dann brauchen
wir nur noch ein ei das macht den teig
einfach so ein bisschen geschmeidiger
später und wasser am besten auf haben
dann verbindet es sich am besten und
dann könnten wir das ganze einfach nur
zu einem schönen teil
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt den teig auf der
arbeitsfläche 345 minuten richtig schön
geschmeidig geknetet wenn ihr merkt dass
der echt zu klebrig ist dann dürfte so
ein bisschen mehr noch dazu schon das
habe ich auch gemacht es kommt halt auch
immer auf die größe des ice an es ist
nicht immer milliliter genau die wasser
angabe oder oder gramm genau die mail
angabe wichtig ist dass so ein richtig
schöner softer teig entsteht der muss
sich so anfühlen wie ein ohrläppchen da
könnt ihr gerne mal einfach mal dran
fühlen den gebe ich jetzt hier einfach
in die schüssel zurückdenken ab und dann
sollte der so 30 minuten einfach nur
entspannen da muss jetzt nicht aufgehen
oder so da ist dagegen kein keine hefe
oder so was drin der muss einfach
entspannt damit er sich gleich beim
aufrollen nicht zusammen zieht wir
nutzen jetzt aber die zwischenzeit und
macht schon mal die herstellung fertig
für die füllung nehme ich jetzt rinder
hackfleisch meint ist jetzt relativ
fettarm hätte ich vorher gewusst dass
ich das rezept heute machen hätte ich
mir fertiges rindfleisch genommen weil
fertig dass es immer besser weil wir
werden das jetzt gleich nicht garen das
kommt in den teig raimund sieger im
wassergarten braucht euch keine sorgen
machen es wird komplett gar und dadurch
dass es gleich eben ja wenig fett
enthält könnt ihr entweder öl dazu geben
oder wochen später nochmal schmandt
könnt ihr auch schmandt mit dazu geben
was ich jetzt aber zuerst mache ich
folgendes ich bleibe jetzt erstmal meine
zwiebeln schön rein schön auch mit dem
saft und so alles schön rein und dann
wird es gesalzen gefahr da kommt noch
paprikapulver dazu ein bisschen chili
wenn ihr mögt und daneben noch der
schwanz
[Musik]
so die füllung ist jetzt fertig und der
teil konnte auch gut entspannen und
jetzt machen wir weiter indem wir
einfach den teig aus der schüssel nehmen
das schöne ist der dürfte jetzt auch
nicht mehr an der arbeitsfläche kleben
falls doch dürft ihr gerne ganz ganz
wenig mehr noch dazu nehmen ihr könnt
den teils in der hälfte durch tyler mit
dir in immer einfacher ausrollen könnt
oder dritten oder vierten ich mache das
jetzt wirklich im april und nehme jetzt
hier einfach so ein viertel teig oder
ein drittel würde ich sagen
soll was kommt zurück und dann sehr sehr
dünn ausbreiten also ich zeige euch
gleich am besten wie dünn dann könnt ihr
das sehen das ist glaube ich millimeter
so nach gefühl und dann stehe ich nur
uns kreise aus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
den restlichen teil könnt jetzt einfach
noch mal zu einer kugel formen und dann
auch noch mal schön gehen lassen damit
er wieder entspannen kann und
anschließend wieder ausräumt meine größe
von von dem ausstecher ist jetzt 5 cm es
ist für mich so dass minimum bis
fünfeinhalb oder sechs nehmen und jetzt
nehme ich mir hier immer so einen teig
nehmen uns vorsichtig und andres quasi
also das war jetzt die oberseite drews
quasi um in meiner haben und dann kommt
da nur ein bisschen von der fleisch
füllung rein aber nicht zu viel sonst
gilt es über und dann kommt es raus und
das wollen wir unbedingt vermeiden
und dann ist es ganz ganz wichtig dass
ihr das hat um klappt so beim umklappen
lässt ihr quasi ein rand außen und
diesen rand den müssen mit ganz ganz
dünn also mit den fingern
zusammenpressen sodass der ganz dünn
wird sondern habt ihr quasi innen diese
füllung also ist diese tasche und
ausland ganz dünnen feinen rand dann
müsst ihr euch mal viel zeit für nehmen
dass sich die zeit aufwendigste bad sagt
dann nimmt er quasi die enden und dann
so zusammen und dann bildet sich hier
diese schöne typische perry form
[Musik]
ich habe die fertigen per mini jetzt
einfach auf mein back weggegeben
bisschen mehl untendrunter damit sie
auch leicht anheben könnte das hier ist
so ungefähr ein fünftel von dem was ich
heute produziere aber ich fange auch
schon mal an das ganze jetzt erst mal
gar zu kochen dafür braucht ihr einfach
nur kochendes wasser geben jetzt salz
nicht dazu für den geschmack und dann
gibt er die per 1 und sobald sie an der
oberfläche schwimmen sind sie gar wie
gesagt er braucht euch keinen stress
machen wegen dem fleisch das wird auf
jeden fall gegart bei der hitze und
nebenbei mache ich noch mein topping da
nimmt er dann einfach schwand gibt salz
dazu ein bisschen knoblauch und dann
könnte das alles zusammen servieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
noch ein kleiner tipp von mir wenn ihr
das nochmal so ein bisschen mit öl
beträufeln möchte dann tut das gerne ich
nehme hier olivenöl ihr könntet auch
butter nehmen dann schmilzt es einfach
in der rest hitze so habt ihr erst noch
mal ein bisschen geschmack und zweitens
kleben die ja nicht so einander so tun
sie auch so nicht es sei denn ihr lasst
es halt nur weil bestehen dann mögen die
das gerne dass die so ein bisschen
aneinander kleben daher einfach ein
bisschen öl dazu geben schrieb ich
gleich noch die zweite ladung dazu und
dann kommt das topping oben drauf und
dann rufe ich den herrn satz im test
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich brauche jetzt auf jeden fall noch
ein bisschen zeit alle per mini zu
befüllen des werden weitaus mehr als ich
glaube ein bisschen als 200 das ding ist
per mini ist halt so wenn man macht viel
arbeit das ist viel handarbeit wie könnt
ihr dabei meditieren oder lasst eure
serien nebenbei laufen so mache ich es
oft oder inhalten podcast oder sowas und
dann könnt ihr aber auch weil er ist ja
nicht alles an einem tag ihr könnt das
einfrieren und das macht einfach
folgendermaßen lebt mail einfach auf ein
schneidebrett oder auf irgend ein
brettchen und gebt die per mini dann
einzeln und nicht überlassen und auf das
schneidebrett gibt es dann für 15
minuten ins gefrierfach und sind sie
nämlich ein bisschen fester und dann
könnt ihr sie einfach in eine dose tun
die auch für das gefrierfach geeignet
ist dann könnt ihr die monate lang
aufbewahren und wenn ihr die dann
zubereitet könnt ihr sie einfach nur ins
kochende wasser geben und dann habt ihr
immer frische per mini quasi auf vorrat
solcher größe per mini gemacht sie
möglichst heute sorgen warum
also das ist mit feststellung dass wir
dieses typische motive wissen
ja man muss auch nicht in der karte also
die afghanischen motto sogar leckeres
man
selbst damit alle alle türken hier unter
uns alles alle teigtaschen mit
hackfleisch füllungen oder
ganz ehrlich man schmeckt mit jedem
besuch finde ich einfach diese
handarbeit und man schätzt es ist noch
ganz anders merkst du solltest du
also man schmeckt das nicht schwarz auf
weiß eltern sogar das natürlich ist das
gibt nochmal geschmack schön dass ihr
sei aufgefallen ist hinten drauf gemacht
das find ich auch jetzt feiere ich auch
glaubwürdigkeit der nacht ganze schweiz
wie es einordnen surgical am ende ja
auch logisch pause habe ich nicht dass
bevor ich diese kisten ich muss jetzt
hier weitermachen also es ist
zeitaufwendig aber sie schmeckt es
kräfte lieber
raus aber das kann ich mit wand- oder
man tiefe gleich am nächsten
nein das ist doch für sich indes die
arbeit alles ist
schön in diese rein einfach mehr geld
ganz ehrlich ich wusste gar nicht dass
wir so gut großen also ich bin bereits
beendet das ersticken ich wünsche euch
viel spaß und nach machen wenn euch das
video gefallen hat wenn du noch auf
jeden fall den daumen nach oben damit
sofort die uns und dann sehen wir uns
auch wenn demnächst wieder
[Musik]